the average starting salary for the
class of 2022 is projected to be more
than fifty thousand okay checks out
however current college students expect
to earn twice that a hundred and three
thousand eight hundred and eighty
dollars in their first job according to
one report yeah that's a problem I
interviewed a bunch of high schoolers
and when I talked to them they all were
like well yeah I'm gonna make a I'm
gonna make six figures when I graduate
and I was like what makes you think that
right there's no reality it's just kind
of this wet finger in the air and I
think I deserve and the the way things
are going with the economy you need to
make a hundred thousand so I'm just
gonna go make a hundred thousand yeah
and it says ten years into the careers
students anticipate making more than two
hundred thousand dollars yeah well so
they are way overestimating their
starting salaries one report says by 88
and so they need to understand what
degree am I after what are the jobs on
the other side of that degree and what
do those jobs pay in my area with my
experience